This is a follow on the question below I am having severe leg cramps almost early in the morning on a daily basis when I finished my chemo three years ago, I was told to take I believe 800 milligrams of calcium every day.
I take Algae Cal Plus and Osteo Force with TVGO and ADK also. So I take them on alternate days. I have taken four infusions in Zomena six months apart.
The last infusion was nearly a year ago. I believe I may be taking too much calcium in my potassium levels may be off effectiveness.
Am I taking too much calcium? What are your thoughts about adding potassium? I took an MRI of my feet and legs on the recommendation of the podiatrist to see if I plant a fasciitis but have not received the results yet.
Your thoughts there my legs ache when I walk or have to climb steps.
It does not stop me from walking and doing exercise in my right leg. I believe has some neuropathy as a result of the genome therapy.
You see the 2020 could indicate vascular problems. What do you recommend?
So how much calcium should a person take even if they have osteoporosis or osteolytic metastasis cancer?
The common thought in nutritional circles for a long time has been that you have to increase the calcium if you have osteoporosis because you have a deficiency in calcium.
If you listen to me for very long at all, you will understand that that has been debunked a long time ago by numerous studies and by numerous just understanding the physiology of osteoporosis even understanding the physiology of bold growth.
It has the osteo force product that is a product from the size of health. It does not have a high dose calcium.
And the TVGO have no calcium in it. So really you're a real calcium source is the 800 milligrams of calcium that you're getting in the algae count plus and the combined with what's in the osteoporosis.
That's really probably too much calcium. So I would agree with you obviously whoever asked this question has read some things calcium because they're asking the question is there's too much calcium I think the answers yes.
Studies that have been shown where they used to recommend 1,500 milligrams of calcium for women, especially on postmenopausal because you have an increase in osteoporosis postmenopausal.
But that has to do with the fluctuation of formal levels that increases inflammation.
So it is really decreasing inflammation and the whole that's going to help the bone uptake calcium.
So it's not increasing blood calcium levels because if you're going to take a whole bunch of calcium you're complete a whole bunch of calcium into the blood.
Your body cannot have calcium into the blood in the blood like that member your body has to your blood has to be buffered.
That's going to be too much alkalinity in the blood. It's going to push it to the tissues calcium is going to be pushed to the tissues and the blood vessels themselves and it can cause and it has been shown because
there's been a huge increase in heart issues and bio-cardial infarctions and women end up taking you know the recommended 1,500 milligrams of calcium that just literally skyrocketed that because there's been books written about it about how you should not be taking that much exogenous meaning it's supplemental for calcium.
Plus the source of calcium is usually calcium carbonate which makes it even worse.
So no, I think you should probably drop back on your calcium levels. Certainly you could take potassium but maybe even better yet look at your blood test.
If you are not deficient in potassium, you probably shouldn't be taking any extra potassium if that's not an issue.
Other reasons why you can have legs cramping at things is not usually a calcium issue if it is a mineral deficiency, it's usually a magnesium deficiency or iron deficiency.
So you have to look at your blood test and make sure that you are anemic.
So people that are anemic meaning to have low iron they will end up having leg cramps and and things like that because of the anemia.
Now it's a cat you're in a catch 22 if you have a current ongoing cancer because you don't want to necessarily be pumping a whole bunch of iron into the system because iron can be a fuel source of cancer.
It's kind of post cancer, you're at a state of remission, there's nothing wrong with taking some iron if you are anemic.
So you take iron based upon your blood test, a CBC would be the blood test that I'm talking about.
Also a CBC at a complete metabolic battle would show calcium levels and potassium levels too.
Other reasons why a person can be have leg cramps, I said magnesium deficiency that's where leg Epsom salt baths would really be helpful for a person with that and post neuropathy so you could have neurological issues causing leg cramps.
Because there's damage to the neurons from a chemical damage from the chemotherapy so post chemo patients tend to have damage of neurons, especially large diameter effort neurons that's the that's the type of neuron that carries pain and carries
tingleed, it carries hot and cold back to the brain, back to the spinal cord and back to the brain.
And those are the highly metabolic and the most easily damaged with chemotherapy and with the diabetic neuropathy as well.
So doing I had pro ways, which leads to the question of the effectiveness of a 50 talks to it, I have pro ways can be helpful for people who have neuropathy.
So I would say do that also that little piece of equipment called the rebuilder, which stimulates the nerve to help grow back if you have neuropathy.
That's not going to help if you have a, you know, ademia or a mineral deficiency, but if you have neuropathy that has to do with the damage of the neurons, then the rebuilder would help with that too.
There's other issues that could cause this to intermittent claudication, we discussed this last week and last week's zoom call or the week before so make sure you look back at that.